تشهد العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين السعوديه
وتايلاند في الفتره الاخيره حراكا غير
مسبوق في مختلف القطاعات الاستثماريه وذلك
بعد تفعيل الاتفاقيات الموقعه بين البلدين
للوصول بالعلاقات الى مرحله الشراكه
الاقتصاديه الاستراتيجيه والتي ساهمت
بدورها في تسارع وتيره التكامل الاقتصادي
ما ادى الى رفع حجم التبادل التجاري
بمقدار 29% في عام 2021 مقارنه بعام 2020
ليصل حجم التجاره بين البلدين في العام
2021 لما قيمته سبعه مليارات ومئه مليون
دولار امريكي بفائضا لصالح السعوديه في
سجل الميزان التجاريه مجالات التكامل
الاقتصادي اخذت منحنا جديده بعد عوده
العلاقات بين بنك والرياض حيث تحتل
السعوديه المرتبه الرابعه 10 في قائمه
الشركاء التجاريين لواردات تايلا من
العالم بقيمه تتجاوز 6 مليارات و800 مليون
دولار امريكي والمرتبه التاسعه والعشرين
في قائمه الشركاء التجاريين لصادرات
تايلاند الى العالم بقيمه مليار و600
مليون دولار امريكي وفي تطور المتسارع
توجت الرياض بانكوك علاقاتهم الاقتصاديه
بتاسيس مجلس اعمال سعودي تايلانديه لتوسيع
نطاق التعاون بينهما في مختلف المجالات
الحيويه بما في ذلك في قطاعات الطاقه
النوويه والطاقه المتجدده والهيدروجين
الاخضر وفي ظل مساعد دولتين لدعم استقرار
اسواق البترول العالميه وضمان امدادات
جميع مصادر الطاقه اتفق الجانبان على
اتخاذ تايلاند مقارا لتخزين النفط وتصديره
الى دول منطقه شرق اسيا وجنوبها شرقيه حيث
تعد السعوديه شريكا رئيسيا في مجال الطاقه
لتايلاند خصوصا في امدادات النفط الخام
اما في مجال الزراعه فعمل البلدان على
تسهيل تجاره المحاصيل الاساسيه وخاصه
الارز فضلا عن رغبه السعوديه في تصدير
التمور للاسواق التايلنديه وتعزيز التعاون
مع الجانب التايلندي في مجال الاستزراع
السمكي ومنتجات الدواجن بالاضافه الى
اطلاق مشروعات وشراكات في مختلف القطاعات
بين البلدين وتسهيل التنقل والسفر لاغراض
التجاره والسياحه والاستشفاء لمواطن
البلدين واستكشاف مجالات الاستثمار والفرص
المتاحه والمشاريع الكبرى المرتبطه برؤيه
السعوديه 2030